[Music]
so
after we survived hurricane katrina
we thought that we could survive
anything
and we were wrong
they found 45 dead bodies there
now does that make any sense to you
i'm under a great deal of pressure to
look into what happened there were five
days the most ungodly conditions
we are getting all of these patients out
of here we are nurses
and we're going to get it done
as long as we don't get left behind
[Music]
we have to be realistic about the
situation
there is nothing else to do for them
except to make them comfortable
so what are we talking about
asked me to look into the deaths at
memorial about the senate
the attorney general's office is
focusing their investigation on you
they're suggesting that some of their
patients lives may have been ended
i am sure that patients do not suffer
pain
some people were afraid of people
outside of the hospital
but for me
it was the other way around
if you were given choice between
comforting patient
possibly quickening his death
or
abandoning patients to suffer a slow
death
what would you choose to do
all i did was try to help people that is
all i did
[Music]
you